now power sharing in Northern Ireland is
teetering on the brink of collapse this
weekend deadline after deadline has
passed with no deal between the two main
parties and also with no sign of a
breakthrough on the horizon so there's a
very real chance of direct rule from
Westminster being imposed so potentially
not the ideal time you might think for
the new shadow Northern Ireland
secretary own Smith to ease himself into
the job we can now speak to him from his
home near Cardiff oh sorry looking in
the wrong place their own Smith I am
going to straight town here thank you
for coming on the show this morning
there's lots to talk to you about about
your Northern Ireland brief which we'll
come to but of course many people will
remember you as the man who challenged
Jeremy Corbyn last year new said for his
leadership at the time was a cataclysmic
failure leaving labour teetering on the
brink of obscurity what doesn't quite
seem that way after the election does it
why did you get him so wrong well I
think in keeping with a lot of people in
this country my view Sophie was that
Labour wasn't going to get close to
winning with Jeremy as our leader
I've said previously I was clearly wrong
about that because we did very well at
the election gained 30 seats almost 30
million votes I wasn't anticipating that
and Jeremy in that regard absolutely
proved me wrong and proved many people
wrong and we are now in with the chance
of winning in election the Tories are
clearly riven right now they could
collapse at any moment and labour needs
to stand ready to form a government if
you had won that leadership election do
you think you'd have done as well as
Jeremy Corbyn did I don't know I hope so
I hope I might have even got us to win
but I can't know that Sophie look I
think Jeremy is clearly galvanized young
people in this country we've seen that
not just in the election but since I met
people dueling the election who hadn't
voted ever certainly people who hadn't
voted for a long while
who felt Jeremy was speaking to and for
them and the Labour was speaking to and
for them and I don't think any of us can
argue with that and therefore I think
he's earned the right to try and get
labour into power and earn the right to
be our next Prime Minister now one of
the things that you were perhaps most
passionate about during that leadership
I can't
was breakfast and the UK's relationship
with the EU I just want to read to you a
couple of things that you said in March
my view is absolutely crystal clear that
we should be members of the single
market and then you said when we leave
the single market we will have a lesser
level of benefits than we currently
enjoy but when you have a chance to vote
in favour of staying in a single market
this week you abstained
so did you sell out your principles for
a front bench job no I think my view
hasn't changed I still believe that
brexit is a is a bad decision for us as
a country and is going to leave us worse
off that's my personal view but jeremy
corbyn's asked me to do a very important
job on the front bench for labour in
Northern Ireland at a point at which
Northern Ireland is central to British
politics and therefore I think my duty
is to get on and try and do that job and
to work as part of it as I say a Labour
government in Waiting at the same time
there you have had some pretty strong
things about that single market
membership in the past so I do just want
to stay on this for a moment
because you said that it was the biggest
gut FIB that the government is telling
right now that we're going to be able to
enjoy the exact same benefits outside
the single market as we currently enjoy
I mean that is Labour's position now so
why is it a fib when the government says
it and not a feared one neighbor says it
well at my view Sophie is that we are
going to find out over the next couple
of months that the government can't
deliver on what they promised which is
to give us the exact same benefits as we
currently enjoy in the single market and
the customs union and at that point I
think the country may well find itself
looking down the barrel of a brexit that
is going to leave us worse off and some
of the arguments that some of us have
made in the past and will continue to
make within the labour party
respectfully with our colleagues may
well feel a bit more relevant then so
now in other ways she must disagree then
with the leadership a position the
leadership for example John MacDonald
Shadow Chancellor calling on the
government to negotiate a deal but
retains the same benefits to UK houses
and then with the single market the
labor manifesto that pledges to
negotiate a brexit to retain the
benefits of the single market you think
that's impossible that's not going to
happen I think it's for the government
to prove
that can happen I think they are the
ones who've said that they are going to
give us exactly the same benefits as we
currently enjoy and they are the ones
who need to prove that they can deliver
that laborious said we want to make sure
the jobs are prioritized we want to make
sure that investment in this country is
safeguarded and I think all of those
things are not earring set
irreconcilable with a view I hold and I
will continue to hold those views and to
make that argument within government
it's easy though isn't it just to throw
the whole thing on to the government
that they've got to prove it it's all in
their court but actually a responsible
position they're not really there it
should be a responsible position that
says that you are a government in
Waiting that you're preparing for
another election don't unions get this
sort of stuff sorted out as well well I
think you've articulated Sophie already
what Labour's position is you know it's
for investment and jobs to be
safeguarded for the government to
deliver on their promise of exact same
benefits that we currently enjoy and I
think we've got to hold their feet to
the flames on this you know labour isn't
in power yet labour wants to be in power
but crucially it is the Tories who've
led us to the brink in respective brexit
is David Davis who's making such a
Horlicks of the negotiations and it's
over the next couple of months when we
really get down to the nitty-gritty of
what brexit is actually going to look
like are we going to see the extra money
for the NHS all the lies that were told
then we will I think be able to properly
hold the government to account and show
the country what brexit might mean let's
talk about Northern Ireland because
deadline after deadline has been missed
to try and form a government now how
concerned are you about the future of
power sharing very because it's very
clear to me talking to all of the
parties in Northern Ireland the whilst
some progress has been made and
negotiations are not happening today but
will be ongoing as I understand it
tomorrow there's still a big gulf
between the parties and there is still a
big gap in terms of that crucial
ingredient trust because whatever the
issues on the table unless the parties
trust one another to work together or at
least have got sufficient transparency
as the other's motives and intentions
then we won't get power sharing back up
and running that's the lesson of history
in Northern Ireland I was there as an
adviser
when we were trying to do something
similar when direct rule was
reintroduced back in 2002 to five and it
is a very very difficult job to rebuild
trust once it's been lost you talk about
the gulf between the parties if there
isn't an agreement then the government
has a choice or another election or
impose direct rule again which choice
would you make well I absolutely I think
I either choice to be honest are pretty
ugly choices for Northern Ireland so I'm
not sure what I would urge James broken
shy to take either of those choices as
you outline them if you get into direct
rule it's very easy to introduce it's
the devil's own job to get out of it and
another election well if we think we're
sick of elections in the GB they are
truly sick of them in Northern Ireland
so I don't detect any appetite for that
I think the Secretary of State is going
to need to find a third way of some sort
but I think crucially he's gonna need to
get his government to redouble their
efforts the truth is the Tory party I
think viewed Northern Ireland's the
problem that was solved they haven't
concentrated on it over the last seven
years David Cameron barely went to
Northern Ireland Theresa May I think has
only been once to Northern Ireland she's
hardly met with the political parties
they need to pull their finger out
frankly and offer a bit more energy into
all of this if it is going to be
resolved because without that maybe it
does require the Prime Minister to
become directly involved without that
sort of engagement then history again
tells us it won't be resolved do you
think the relationship between the
Conservative Party and the DP is
impacting the situation in Northern
Ireland at all I don't think anybody can
say but that is happening because you
know all of the parties in Northern
Ireland too aren't the DUP worried that
the DUP now have extra influence they
have the ear of the government and I
don't think anybody can argue against
that I've heard the Tories trying to
spin that this is a entirely separate
process in Westminster and installment
but the reality on the ground is that it
is making it more difficult for trusts
to be restored now I hope that can be
surmounted I hope that the parties can
get past that but for the Tories to say
that that isn't an issue frankly is
being a bit disingenuous